bonsoir le journal de la rédaction
chaque soir à 18h en direct une nouvelle
édition pour faire le tour de
l'actualité locale et voici les titres
de ce 10 septembre
il est le chef de la sécurité sécurité
publique dans les yvelines thomas boudou
vient de sortir son premier roman
policier
tout en bas de la falaise pas
d'anecdotes sur son parcours mais de
quoi vous tenir en haleine alors que la
rentrée littéraire est vampirisée par
ouvrage de l'ancienne première dame
canal + diffuse ce soir un documentaire
autour de l'improvisation et de sa place
dans l'éducation au coeur du reportage
jamel debbouze alain degois le fondateur
de déclic théâtre
et puis un institut d'études politiques
dans les yvelines c'est une première
cela faisait 20 ans à travers la france
qu aucune création n'avait été possible
si on se pose saint germain en laye
vient d'ouvrir ses portes à 80 étudiants
l'emploi se porte mal dans l'automobile
et cela concerne forcément les yvelines
premier département automobile de france
les plus grands groupes y sont implantés
notamment à saint quentin en yvelines
alors que le mondial parisien de
l'automobile s'ouvrira dans un mois
l'urssaf révèle que les constructeurs
ont vu leurs effectifs chuté de 8,7 pour
cent en un an
en cinq ans dix mille emplois perdus
juste pour la région francilienne et
dans le département et blinois on se
souvient déjà de ce millier
d'intérimaires poussé vers la sortie par
renault flins ou encore peugeot poissy
ce mercredi soir canal+ diffuse donc un
documentaire de 90 minutes consacré à
l'improvisation déclic théâtre la troupe
d'improvisation de trappes une vraie
reconnaissance pour cette compagnie
créée voici une vingtaine d'années
catherine château et patrick jacques de
leeds
quand on parle de des kits théâtre on
évoque souvent jamais de blues
le comédien originaire de trappes qui a
fait ses débuts et il n'a pas oublié ses
anciens compagnons de patinoire pendant
une année une équipe de tournage a suivi
les comédiens une reconnaissance pour le
président fondateur de la troupe alain
degois
effectivement il ya longtemps je vous
dis il faudrait faire quelque chose de
long ça vaut le coup cette discipline
vaut le coup d'être d'être regardée dans
la longueur et non pas là le fait que ce
soit sur un an qu'on puisse voir une
évolution ça pas simplement le match il
ya des scènes de jeu trouve touchante
touchante de la parole de ces jeunes qui
parlent de leurs activités de la parole
des mamans de ces jeunes qui regardent
leurs enfants
autrement il ya des paroles de maman je
n'aurais pas eu ces paroles là il ya
cinq ou dix ans parce que d'un seul coup
elles s'aperçoivent que ça peut être un
outil important pour l'éducation de
l'enfant dans ce documentaire de 90
minutes produit par mélissa theuriau et
diffusé ce soir sur canal+
on y voit longuement jamel debbouze lui
qui a démarré avec déclic c'était au
collège donc de découverte jamais elle
qui nous parle de cette discipline est
et ce qu'elle lui a apporté et ya même
un moment donné on vous envoie dans le
reportage a failli il prend un peu les
rênes du court et on sent que ça lui
rappelle les moments où il était lui
même en train de donner des cours ici
sur saint quentin et on sent bien qu'il
a il a sa route sont quand même
l'improvisation comme vecteur culturel
mais aussi sociale à travers le travail
fait par la troupe en d'entreprise au
sein de la fondation culture et
diversité concrétisée par un trou ça met
en évidence
que le profil des gens importe peu en
improvisation dans la mesure où
l'important c'est d'avoir des profils
différents pour pouvoir créer du mélange
le fait de reprendre confiance en soi de
reprendre confiance en l'école voilà
notre travail qu'on peut faire nous dans
le cadre de nos ateliers qui est un peu
le travail de fourmi s'attacher un
profil de profil ça on le ressent
vraiment bien dans le film on ressent
vraiment bien aussi bas que c'est une
pratique de compétition parce que c'est
la réalité et puis c'est une pratique
mix la compagnie déclic théâtre a
célébré ses 20 ans l'année dernière
documentaire à découvrir donc sur la
chaîne cryptée canal+ ce mercredi un
dixième institut d'études politiques a
ouvert ses portes à saint germain en
laye dans les yvelines un lieu paix
porté par deux universités dont celles
de versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines
anthony rech le des moines étaient
présents cet après midi avec les
étudiants ses premiers pas sont en
quelque sorte historique
ces étudiants sont les premiers de
l'institut d'études politiques de saint
germain en laye mais la particularité de
ce 10e et ep est ailleurs ses liens avec
ces deux facultés fondatrice cergy
pontoise et l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines dont 40% des
enseignants sont issus l'objectif créer
à terme des passerelles entre les
établissements
d'une part on met en place des
dispositifs de préparation aux concours
dans les lycées publics et à
l'université et puis il est prévu en
l'ouverture d'un concours quatrième
année qui sera spécifique puisque on en
ouvrira des places par sections et qui
seront ouverts aux étudiants des
universités donc les passerelles oui on
les crée cette première promotion de
lieux pays de l'eee noah se compose de
80 des étudiants pour 41 professeurs ils
bénéficieront d'une formation sur cinq
ans dont la dernière dans un des master
2 de l'uv skis ou de cergy pontoise et
si les plus pessimistes tendent à penser
que cette première promotion va essuyer
les plâtres du côté des élèves
participer à cette aventure est une
vraie chance
la première chrome os bas c'est vrai
qu'on insiste vient selon la directrice
avait insisté sur le fait que bah sinon
qu'elles ont marqué un peu l'image de
libé et c'est donc une responsable en
exil ou hergé tous contents de pouvoir
créer plein de choses ainsi vu que tout
est à faire genre de pouvoir faire nos
associations le truc à la fin de leur
cursus ils seront alors titulaire d'un
double diplôme de lieux paix et de leur
université de rattachement pour
peut-être devenir les chefs d'entreprise
de demain
fluidifier le trafic un engagement pris
par alexandra rossetti pendant sa
campagne municipale à voisins le
bretonneux les électeurs apprécieront
sans doute donc ce test lancé au
croisement de la route de trappes et de
versailles pendant trois mois à la
circulation est donc modifié de quelle
manière claire cambier nous l'expliquent
attention cycle de feu modifié à voisins
le bretonneux une réorganisation du
fonctionnement des feux tricolores a été
mise en place au niveau du croisement
entre la route de versailles et celle de
trappes une phase de test pendant trois
mois qui a pour but de fluidifier le
trafic
une solution promise par la mer
alexandra rosetti lors de sa campagne
car les habitants sont lassés des
bouchauds en période de pointe
on perd du temps en fait c'est une perte
de temps oui surtout le soir lui
toujours le feu
comment ça change très vite au fait qu'à
très peu de voitures qui passent à la
fois en 2012 une onde verte a été créé
sur la rd 36 les feux sont dorénavant
coordonnées sauf sur ce carrefour car la
circulation ne le permettait pas
conséquence des bouchons quotidiens la
demande de la ville de voisins le
bretonneux c'était justement de pouvoir
leur entrée dans cette coordination est
là on a changé la programmation des feux
pour raccourcir le cycle en fait donc on
fonctionnait avant sur une durée totale
de cycle de 120 secondes et aujourd'hui
on est passé à 90 secondes avec la
nouvelle programmation
les automobilistes devraient donc passer
moins de temps au feu rouge pour
modifier le cycle de ses feux tricolores
les voix de présélection pour tourner à
gauche ont été supprimés un rond-point
amovible trône dorénavant au centre du
carrefour
si les résultats sont concluants au bout
des trois mois d'expérimentation le
système sera pérennisée on passe à
l'invité de cette édition du 10
septembre et les policiers depuis plus
de 20 ans chef de la sûreté
départementale dans le département des
yvelines il s'est lancé dans l'écriture
d'un roman policier forcément bonsoir
bonsoir
quarante deux ans auteur de tout en bas
de la falaise aux éditions amalthée
voici cet ouvrage le vôtre votre premier
roman une enquête autour d'un suicide
qui finalement on n'est peut-être pas un
c'est l'intrigué qui sera dévoilée en
suit l'intrigué qui se passe à dieppe où
l'on suit l enquête la de tristan rondot
un secteur que vous connaissez bien vous
avez été commissaire là bas mais la
comparaison s'arrête ici ce n'est pas
votre histoire vous raconter que les
choses soient bien claires
non ce n'est pas autobiographique si
c'est ça la question mais toujours est
il que dans le livre je me livre quand
même un petit peu
de par mon expérience où l'avait dit de
20 ans de police effectivement il ya des
forcément il ya des similitudes dans les
personnages dans les histoires dans les
atmosphères les ambiances que j'avais pu
décrire dans mon lit c'est un inspecteur
qui n'est pas très très à l'aise du côté
de dieppe il vit assez mal d'être mise à
l'écart de paris voilà c'est même un
commissaire de police qui donc un chef
de service qui est affectée contre sa
volonté sur sur dieppe en normandie et
qui va tout faire pour en repartir
et donc cette enquête là peut-être va
lui permettre d'en sortir de retourner
sur paris mais ce n'est pas un élément
autobiographique il faut étiez content a
dit elle pas du tout non j'ai passé un
an à dieppe et j'aurais bien voulu en
passe et plus mais bon il est clair que
j'ai beaucoup aimé dieppe à la fois les
paysages et puis les gens que j'ai pu
rencontrer qui sont vraiment des gens
très attachants
l'histoire qui se déroule notamment en
normandie avec son corps retrouvé au
pied d'une falaise lorsque vous exerciez
sur place vous vous êtes dit justement
avec ces affaires qui arrivent et parce
que des suicides de ce genre il devait y
en avoir
malheureusement peut-être assez
fréquemment et puis le cadre si vous
vous êtes dit il faut faire un roman
autour de ça le cadre est idéal
oui c'est je suis partie déjà du constat
que des personnes venaient de la région
parisienne pour pour se suicider donc
sur les côtes normandes faire le dernier
saut en fait tout simplement et donc du
coup
partant de ce constat là et puis le
paysage aidant je me suis dit que
c'était le début d'une intrigue c'est le
début d'une intrigue mais il faut avoir
le temps de l'écrire ensuite cette
intrigue parce que vous êtes le chef de
sûreté départementale dans les yvelines
vous étiez d'ailleurs déjà venu en
plateau à ce titre nous parler de votre
travail travail très prenant
vous avez écrit entre 2007 et 2013
plusieurs années d'écriture et à quel
moment vous avez écrit exactement donc
ça fait ça fait presque sept ans il n'ya
pas sept ans d'écriture puisqu'il ya eu
des périodes où où j'ai beaucoup produit
puis des périodes un peu moins bon il
est vrai que là où j'ai eu le
le plus le temps de décrire et puis le
plus d'inspiration c'était pendant la
période qui suit la période de dieppe
c'est à dire j'étais commissaire de nuit
dans l'essonne où effectivement vers 3 4
heures du matin il m'arrivait de jeter
quelques quelques lignes sur un papier
c'est comme ça que qu'est venu le début
de mon roman
puisqu'on parle de ce parcours justement
vous aviez cette envie d'être policier
véritablement aujourd'hui vous écrivez
vous n'imaginez pas changer de carrière
ah non pas du tout et puis ce serait un
peu nan moi j'ai toujours voulu être
policier comme on dit c'est c'est c'est
vraiment une vocation un pour moi donc
j'ai fait des études commerciales mais
je savais dès le départ que je
reviendrai à ce que je souhaitais faire
dès le départ c'est à dire un policier à
policier donc inspecteur de police dans
un premier temps est au bout de dix ans
j'ai passé le concours de commissaire
voilà donc je suis actuellement
effectivement celle de la sûreté des
yvelines cette rentrée en 94 dans la
police exactement avec quelle motivation
qu'elle sait quelles étaient vos
ambitions
ah ben moi c'est le judiciaire c'est à
dire que il ya plusieurs branches dans
la police elle mille métiers je dirais
même donc la police technique et
scientifique ça existe vous avez aussi
les enquêtes
vous avez aussi l'ordre public vous avez
mille métiers et moi ce qui me passionne
en premier
en premier lieu c'est tout ce qui
concerne les enquêtes les enquêtes
judiciaires donc je suis rentré comme
inspecteur de police en investigation et
là je me retrouve à la tête d'un service
qui fait donc du judiciaire
tout le temps et vous aviez toujours
cette envie d'écrire depuis le début
mais l'écriture oui j'aime bien écrire
je le dis souvent c'est quand on fait
des enquêtes policières
il ya beaucoup de pv procès verbaux des
notifications de garde à vue pleins
pleins d'autres pv qui sont plutôt
normalisé donc il n'y a pas grand-chose
à réfléchir je dirais et il ya un pv qui
s'appelle le procès verbal de
constatation donc où on décrit une scène
de crime par exemple hélas ce pv là
c'est vraiment le pv le plus important
parce que ça permet aux magistrats qui
n'est pas forcément sur place ou même à
un médecin légiste de se faire une idée
de la scène de crime techniques
d'écriture n'est pas tout à fait la même
et c'est même préjudiciable à l'écriture
littéraire
c'était exactement sésame et elle a
raison parce que j'ai créée dès le
départ un comité de lecture avec une
dizaine d'amis de la famille et c'est
vrai que comme vous dites si justement
l'écriture elle va pas de soi je veux
dire c'est parce qu'on est commissaire
de police
c'est pas parce qu'on aime les
impressionnistes qui est mon cas qu'on
va faire un roman fort c'est formidable
je veux dire il est clair qu'au début
c'était compliqué parce que il a fallu
changer un peu à la manière d'écrire
parce que moi j'ai une écriture
vous disiez après un procès verbal de
constatation c'est un procès verbal qui
est quand même très technique et donc
c'est vrai qu'il a fallu roman c'est un
peu tout ça comme il a fallu romance et
les personnages et romancé l'histoire
tout simplement l'entourage a été très
critique au début et oui tout à fait
mais c'est ce que j'avais demandé à et
c'est vrai que bon du coup légaux en
prend un coup je ne vous le cache pas
parce que vous du compte que je vous lis
on pense qu on est bon et puis au bout
du compte on nous dit bah ouais mais là
c'est tu écris bien la plume était là
d'après ce que j'ai pu comprendre le
départ mais par contre là c'était trop
technique et une scène autopsie qui est
trop technique
ça va être très intéressant pour un
après un étudiant en médecine ça l'est
moins pour un quelqu'un qui souhaite
simplement se détendre en lisant un
roman policier
parce que dans l'écriture encore on le
sent à cette volonté aussi du détail
d'expliquer les choses dès que vous
utilisez un terme très précis à une
petite annotation qui explique ce que
ces mêmes dès les premières pages le
document qui consignent les événements
la journée et la nuit ce qui s'est passé
ça s'appelle la main courante
edel débrouiller à la notation pour que
le lecteur ne soient pas perdues parler
de cet entourage très critique parce que
c'est décourageant aussi parfois ben oui
c'est pour ça que je vous dis qu'il ya
eu des périodes où d'abondance au niveau
de l'écriture
et puis des périodes donc juste après
ses critiques là effectivement gémit
quand même deux mois pour m'en remettre
en me disant on va peut-être que c'est
pas le bon chemin ou voilà que je vais
te faire autre chose et puis au bout du
combat on remet le travail sur l'ouvragé
puis on petit abouti ont progressé puis
l'écriture avance toujours sur sur
l'écriture et sur les clins d'oeil
peut-être qu'ils sont faits dans ce
livre adieu poulet avec deux verres les
brigades du tigre aussi voulais
mentionner ça fait partie de notre
culture a passé c'est non seulement
c'est ma culture mais c'est mon univers
aussi même si les films aussi romance un
peu la réalité parce que bon c'est vrai
que là le travail la journée d'un flic
classique c'est quand même pas mal de
temps derrière un ordinateur à à taper
des procès ragots comme je vous le
disais mais effectivement oui je suis je
suis empreint de toute cette culture
culture d'ailleurs même au niveau des
romans jeudi autant de des romans
américains que des romans français même
je suis même jusqu'en islande où votre
ans donc je gèle j'adore ça et la
peinture également vous avez mentionné
les impressionnistes dans votre réponse
tout à l'heure effectivement tout cette
intrigue se déroule sur fond de trafic
d'art avec toutes ces impressionniste
ses tableaux qui vous cette période qui
vous qui vous passionne ça vient d'où
cette passion pour la peinture également
moi c'est que depuis que je suis tout
jeune il a fait le jeu face à un petit
commentaire en sixième sur les
impressionnistes donc j'ai choisi van
gogh et à partir de là je me suis
passionné à la fois pour pour l'homme
d'abord pour sa peinture et après pour
l'homme et puis peu sur les trajectoires
sur les différents endroits où il a été
ou est il a vécu on trouve r3 et puis et
puis c'est un vide provence et puis par
les autres donc en fait on suit un peu
les peintures en même temps il y en a
on suit aussi l'évolution du personnage
qui n'a pas eu que des moments joyeux
loin s'en faut comment vous faites
justement pour entremêlées toutes ses
passions vous pouvez avoir c'est pour la
peinture pour l'écriture les clins
d'oeil que vous faites à tout cet
univers policier
votre métier aussi parce que votre
parcours se retrouve aussi entre les
lignes sur certains sur certains
passages comment vous avez réussi à tout
entremêlé des choix difficiles des
réécriture permanente comment évolue ce
personnage le personnage il
c'est un peu con même si quand je vous
ai dit au départ c'est autobiographique
on qu'on soit bien clair
pour autant il est clair que
ce personnage se nourrit un peu de monde
mon vécu c'est pour ça qu'ils aiment
l'impressionniste c'est pour ça qu'ils
il est comme il est mais toujours est il
que moi moi moi je me suis je suis
curieux de nature et je me suis
intéressé par beaucoup de choses on
parle des impressionnistes la peinture
mais j'aime aussi tout ce qui est
antiquités brocante
parce que tout ce qui finalement est
chargé d'histoire m'intéresse c'est
effectivement ce qu'on ressent à travers
le le livre vous l'imaginez comme un
personnage récurrent ce commissaire de
police
mais écoutez peut-être on verra en tout
cas une suite est possible il a faim il
suffisamment ouverte aussi complètement
ses matches à une chute vous avez déjà
travaillé mais j'ai des idées oui j'ai
même déjà pas mal d'idées en tête mais
maintenant il faut passer à perdre
l'écriture et c'est vrai que là sur le
poste que j'occupe actuellement c'est un
peu compliqué jugée comme une famille à
gérer et de notamment une petite fille
qui est atteinte d'une maladie génétique
c'est un vainqueur
j'allais mal parce qu'il ya un tiers des
droits d'auteur que vous allez dossier
sur cet ouvrage qui seront reversés à
des associations sur verre sur la
recherche pour les maladies génétiques
c'est une cause qui nous touche
particulièrement vous l'avez mentionné
voulait tenir et et expliquer pourquoi
c'est aussi important pour vous oui bon
ben moi j'aime bien voilà j'ai quatre
enfants quatre adorables enfants dont la
dernière la plus petite donc là quatre
ans est atteint d'une maladie génétique
qui s'appelle le syndrome de prader
willi et concède un maladies orphelines
donc
neuromusculaires et donc du coup pendant
100 par exemple ne marche pas il
s'exprime pas vraiment et donc voilà
donc je suis touché par ça et au delà de
ça j'ai toujours milité dans des
associations sur le handicap notamment
et là je me suis dit que la meilleure
manière de militer là par rapport au
temps qui me reste en termes de
disponibilité
c'est effectivement avec la sortie de ce
livre de pouvoir en faire la promotion
d'une part et puis aussi verser un tiers
de mes droits à l'afm téléthon que tu me
connais bien sûr très bien où lille
france
c'est donc cette association qui gère
reprise plus précisément cette maladie
et puis aussi laissé zad qu'on connaît
un peu partout en france et notamment
celui des molières dans un instant cet
ouvrage vous ferai aussi une bonne
action que c'est un ouvrage qui est un
homme très personnel on l'a compris à
travers tous les éléments vous avez
mentionné et en plus cette cette cause
que vous soutenez et qui vous touche par
la suite c'est ce que vous avez d'une
évolution de carrière à l'ats olivier
marchal par exemple flic devenu acteur
réalisateur sait ce qu'elle est en fait
avoir écouté ou une éponge vous fait
rêver ou basse et une belle
un bon parcours on peut pas le nier mais
pour autant pour l'instant je n'en suis
pas là écoutez là je me suis fait
plaisir en écrivant ce livre parce que
finalement c'est quand même mine de rien
c'est quand même un aboutissement
j'étais entre le moment d'écrire et puis
finalement de pouvoir le publier c'est
quand même quelque chose que j'ai pas
forcément passer au départ et puis moi
j'ai quand même quand je vous dis je
j'ai un service très important à gérer
dans le département et donc il nécessite
quand même que je sois à 100% de dans
une adaptation en film
pourquoi pas vous qui aimez ces paysages
aussi ben voilà même si avec ça a dit
l'acteur
exactement voilà ces réalisateurs vous
êtes prenez a en tout cas il va y soit
la date et les fonds seront donnés à des
associations ça ce serait un problème
rencontré dans la question comment se
passe votre rentrée dans vos services
actuellement 100 professionnels sur le
plan professionnel tout va mieux au
monde à quelques affaires dans le
département dont certaines comme vous
savez défraie la chronique
donc moins cher on gère au mieux ces
affaires-là rentrée chargée entre votre
activité professionnelle mais ce soir
vous étiez venu parler de cet ouvrage
tout en bas de la falaise votre premier
roman roman policier
vous savez forcément très vous parlez
merci thomas je vous remercie de la
sûreté départementale des yvelines est
aussi auteur est revenu ce soir pour le
7-8 l'actus et aux éditions amalthée
merci à vous culture jean christophe
bardot a photographié des verriers roi
des habitants de la verrière où des
personnes impliquées dans cette commune
il a également fait participer des
photographes amateurs son travail n'est
pas tout à fait terminé mais il présente
déjà ses premiers travaux dans une
exposition en plein air actuellement sur
le parvis du scarabée la salle
culturelle de la verrière catherine zola
tôt pour aller précision des portraits
qui s'affiche en plein coeur de la ville
de leur ville ils sont installés ou
impliqués à la verrière ces femmes ces
hommes jeunes ou moins jeunes se sont
prêtés au jeu de l'objectif de jean
christophe bardot en quelques photos ils
racontent leur vie dans la ville
je vais les voir une première fois je
leur explique un petit peu le projet le
dispositif un portrait en cinq six sept
images c'est pas juste votre visage qui
m'intéresse c'est comment on voit la
ville de chez vous
objet image une image de famille quelque
chose qui dit d'où vous venez
je vais les voir sur le lieu de travail
je vais les voir sur leurs lieux
d'activités associatives je l'essaie de
les retrouver aussi au milieu des autres
ce qu'il dit c'est pas d'isoler le
portrait c'est de replacer la personne
dans un dans un contexte à la fois faut
que les images elles
elle parle des gens elle a un sens par
rapport à ce qui nous raconte tout ce
qui me propose
quand je leur demande un lieu qui compte
pour eux dans la ville
parfois il ya plusieurs propositions
donc j'ai fait des essais mois ensuite
je vais voir les bas je fais et puis il
ya des choses qui doit leur correspond
mais il ya des choses qui nous touchent
plus photographiquement jean-christophe
bardot a également fait appel à d'autres
photographes amateurs lors d'un atelier
qui a duré six mois
très peu de textes pour accompagner les
photos les images parlent d'elles mêmes
mamadou diawara cet ancien ouvrier de
renault incontournable dans sa ville est
aujourd'hui maire de son village au mali
jean-christophe nos décrit son portrait
en cette photo qu'elle a vue de la
fenêtre il ya le portrait n'est
évidemment le visage qui en général est
pas la première image que je fais
j'attends d'avoir rencontré les gens
plusieurs fois avant de les
photographier parce que c'est pareil un
visage on doit on doit s'y habituer voir
comment ils bougent comment il réagit je
demande à chacun une photo de famille
mais c'est très ouvert la photo de
famille c'est une photo qui parle de des
gens un autre moment
aujourd'hui l'objet c'est l'objet qui
compte pour lui c'est
je demande aussi à tout le monde c'est
son écharpe et son insigne d'élus
maliens j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir
l'accompagner a dit à bigs et plusieurs
fois passer du temps avec lui et donc
donc il me semblait plus intéressant de
le remettre en lien avec ce qu'il a fait
au mali
je les regardais pendant qu'ils
regardent les son portrait est bon il a
dit c'est bien assez bien comment il m'a
dit ah tu m'as pas louper les
photographies sont exposées jusqu'au 16
septembre sur le parvis du scarabée
elles rejoindront ensuite la maison de
quartier à orly parc mais le travail
elle n'est pas fini il reste encore à
jean-christophe bardot une dizaine de
portraits réalisés
l'association des paralysés de france
fêtait sa traditionnelle soirée
champêtre samedi dernier sur le site de
port royal des champs à magny les
hameaux nouveauté cette année
l'inauguration de jardins suspendus avec
cette idée toute simple permettre aux
handicapés et de jardiner plus
d'explications dans ce reportage de
claire cambier et d'anthony rage
du terreau comme une première pierre à
l'édifice des jardins suspendus
le projet de l'association des paralysés
de france ces bacs surélevés en bois
permet aux personnes à mobilité réduite
de découvrir ou redécouvrir les joies du
jardinage
moi qui ne peux plus me mettre debout ça
permettra au moins de travailler assis
au moins pour faire les plantations
éventuellement la récolte il nous ferait
samedi dernier à magny les hameaux
ces jardins suspendus seront accessibles
à tous les adhérents mais aussi aux
autres associations présentes sur le
site de port royal des champs
car le but est de casser la frontière
entre valides et handicapés donc ils
imaginent déjà ses futurs plans de
carottes des radis tomates aussi que le
terrain est prêtée et les bacs ont été
financés par la fondation traîne pour
nick et le jardinage c'est plus qu'un
plaisir il permet de soigner jardiniers
en fait pour les gens c'est c'est se
sentir un peu vive en quoi c'est
s'occuper de plainte c'est créer c'est
ce à dire qu'on peut faire les choses
comme les autres
ces jardins sont accessibles tous les
jours si ce projet d'ortie thérapie
rencontre du succès de nouveaux bacs
seront mis à disposition
en sport tennis de table féminin pour
leurs débuts en croit les joueuses
d'elancourt se sont inclinés face aux
championnes de france en titre vice
championne d'europe lys-lez-lannoy club
nordiste une défaite malgré tout
encourageante quatre matches à de la
rencontre décisive pour l'égalisation
s'étant disputé jusqu'au cinquième set
prochain match à domicile cette fois ci
face au kremlin bicêtre
autre poids lourd du championnat ce sera
le 30 septembre à elle encourt donc et
puis on en revient à cette information
dont nous parlions au début du journal
l'improvisation sera à l'honneur ce soir
sur canal + la journaliste mélissa
theuriau propose une réflexion autour de
la discipline peut-elle être intégrée
aux programmes scolaires pour quel
résultat
jamel debbouze bien sûr alain degois
également ils sont présents c'est à
découvrir dès 20h50
pour ma part je vous retrouve demain
jeudi 18 heures pour un nouveau point
sur l'information locale rediffusion 19h
22h30 et minuit c'est bien sûr à revoir
sur notre site internet a commenté sur
les réseaux sociaux et votre soirée
assure tv fil 78 7 avec catherine cela
tôt pour un nouveau numéro du kiosque le
magazine de la culture